the German capital Berlin is popular
with tourists more than 12 million
visitors arrived last year but among
them were virtually none from Turkey
Ridvan tkachuk is one of about 200,000
residents of Turkish descent living in
Berlin and the current visa rules
frustrating believe me Casper Dino
festival if I see myself as a Berliner
why should I not be able to keep in
touch with my relatives just because
they live in Turkey rather than France
funk lately Britain yep to me it seems
unfair Ridvan could chuck her up in
Germany but his Turkish relatives don't
know what his life here is like it had
cost him 25 euros and application fees
for each of his family members to visit
and he'd need to prove he has thirteen
thousand euros in savings for each guest
now 50 yonder the ones who've long does
this does end up it's hard to believe
that things will change after 50 years
but you should never give up hope you
mentioned he wouldn't offer it's
important for people here and it would
also be good for social harmony if
people could keep up proper links with
their home countries awfully to open can
restaurant owner doggone azman also
thinks it's high time for more freedom
of travel he hopes to welcome more
customers from Turkey Billiat auction
marks knockout or 12 it if we could tap
into the Turkish market we would expect
a twenty-five to thirty percent growth
in turnover since here in central Berlin
nearly eighty percent of our guests are
tourists that would simply toss
instructors gets them as a member of the
German turkeys trade association Dorgan
Osman also thinks the German economy as
a whole would benefit we are often as
business people in Berlin and
Brandenburg we hope visa-free travel
will create more economic opportunities
and give companies a greater incentive
to come to Berlin while at the same time
helping companies from Germany to get
into the Turkish market from talk show
marks is not glitter to present in
Liberal Germans of Turkish to send say
yes to freedom of travel for Turk's but
not at any price lead bothersome that it
would be the
turkish president who would profit the
most politically they think read chapter
you Berta one is putting the EU under
pressure dad isn't bidding on your
finicky I'm fuel I think introducing
visa-free travel under these conditions
is impossible because the consequences
for the people would be even more
catastrophic it's not about being able
to build relationships it's just playing
into the hands of a des portal and I
don't think that's right well just
finish this command is godosan it's
still uncertain if the proposal will get
the green light from the EU bar Germans
of Turkish descent don't expect
visa-free travel to happen anytime soon